Josh starts us off this hour in Richmond
Virginia hey Josh welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how's it going
better than I deserve what's up so I'll
try to give you the backstory my wife
and I just got married in May when we
got married we kind of cleared s
together and figured out that we had a
lot more debt than we thought and I'm
calling specifically about one debt
because it's our car which is about half
of the debt and I wanted to know if we
should sell it or we should keep it
because we're upside down on it so how
much debt have you got total around
eighty one thousand dollars you have a
$40,000 car debt yes sir
um what's on the car uh 2017 Buick
LaCrosse what's it worth
KBB says twenty four good more are you
so far upside down roll negative equity
end of the deal
No so it just appreciated we brought
five new which was a huge mistake but it
kind of you sure you already it's 36
specifically but still it's a lot upside
down 36 is the actual payoff you got
that recently yes like today I made a
car payment today okay when when did you
buy the car um I think the January's
here went down $12,000 and nine months
yeah I've looked at KBB probably once
and everything it straight in or private
sale no that's probably sell tradingview
more ridiculous ratings like 18,000 or
something crazy Wow let's eat you never
bought a new car unless you're rich okay
unbelievable attack so what's your
household income
I run a hundred thousand okay yeah I
would sell this car just because it
sucks yeah horrible I mean there's
nothing in this yeah there's nothing in
this story that makes me anything but
wanna throw
right so yeah I mean saying here but we
were talking to our financial advisor
and he was so our plan my wife's plan
was sell her car and my car
his her car is only about 12 so I could
cover the negative equity and just lop
off around 36 $37,000 that like to
transactions and then we could try to
cash flow another car just around six or
seven something reliable book drive exam
exactly get you a couple three thousand
dollar cars let you pay cash and then
work your way out of debt and then go
buy on the car yeah and your financial
advisor doesn't like that no because he
says that we should be focusing on the
credit cards because they're twenty and
thirty percent and the car loan is only
five well you'll be able to when you get
rid of these car payments and when you
get rid of the financial advisor you'll
have a better plan because he sucks too
okay yeah well then I also wanted to ask
you but like cash flowing the car um me
my wife or both small business owners so
our income is a little irregular and
we're going to what we would call a slow
season from about December until next
spring as we both are in the wedding
industry um how much money can you make
your fall can you get this done this
fall get you to $3,000 cars
yeah the probably do that okay because
but this time next year you're done if
you if you make this move you're done by
this time next year
interest rates are relevant that's why
you need to get a new financial advisor
because you're going to do this so fast
that the interest rates are not they
don't matter here what matters here is
you've gotten you've gotten stuck into a
mud hole and you got to climb out of
that mud hole and I'd look like a Buick
yeah yeah that's what I want to do if I
just wanted to do whatever could get us
out quickness regardless yeah like what
happened by the end of this month have
to $3,000 cars are one three thousand
our car but the end of the next month
have another three thousand dollar car
before the slow season starts and be
done with both of these cars sell them
as quick as you can
cool okay yeah thanks okay yeah and then
you got cash flow coming out your ears
because you make good money you
you just have this card disaster on your
hands and then you cut up the credit
cards of course and of course you're
gonna you know plow right through this
other $40,000 or the debt you can do
that in a year if you got an open at
debt except this right that's it yeah I
wasn't kidding by this time next year
you're debt-free
if you make this move because the cash
and the cash flow implications of this
ridiculous car payment on 40 grand
because you got what a 750 $800 car
payment it's like 600 and then sure
enough court there because I find - yeah
and it's going down $1,000 plus a month
and value yeah holding I'm holding on to
that would be called bad financial
advice okay so right think about it I
think I think you've got good instincts
if I'm you I'm trusting your instincts I
personally if I were in your shoes my
recommendation would be doing what we're
talking about and getting some different
phone I have ice thanks for the call man
we appreciate